if you're a pessimist you might look at
months like January as bone dry when it
comes to video game releases an optimist
however see such a month as a chance to
pay close attention to games that might
have otherwise flown under the radar and
as it happens January of 2015 had a
great many smaller gems worthy of your
time and your loved one of them the
beautiful and imaginative lost
constellation even allows you to pay
what you want so there's no reason not
to engage in its delights the words
beautiful and imaginative also describe
gravity ghost a short puzzle game with
an aesthetic sensibility so unique that
it's hard to escape its pull once you
set eyes on it now is the time to catch
up on what you're missing for us at the
fringes that you find games that are
truly special January also brought us
excellent strategy games in the forms of
grey goo and black guards to grey goo in
particular is a return to form for the
prototypical RTS formula harking back to
a time when Base building and combats
stood on equal footing with starcraft 2
dominating that landscape and with
beloved franchises like command and
conquer apparently left to slowly die
Grey Goose traditional gameplay feels
remarkably fresh in 2015 then there's
black guards to rising from the might
and magic tradition and making it fun to
be a bad guy in a world full of nasty
possibilities if the PC is your gaming
home then January made it perfectly
comfortable to remain there it was a
multi-platform game that most inspired
the gamespot staff however dying light
given its flaws you wouldn't expect it
to gain such favored status but it's
hard to ignore the power of good parkour
this is a game in which you're generally
best off avoiding the crowds of zombies
that fill the streets and gives you the
tools to take to the rooftops and leaf
above the undead dying lights fun factor
is off the charts coming to a head when
day turns to night and the threat keeps
you racing through the streets as well
as above them this
is when tensions rise your heart thumps
loudly and you alternately hide and
sprint knowing the peril is always only
a few steps away we therefore named
dying light as gamespot's game in the
month for January 2015 22 its uncanny
ability to make running for your life so
enjoyable